in adrian tchaikovsky's children of time
humanity is spreading out into the stars
but not with colonies but with
evolutionary science
we have seeded a number of planets with
apes and a special
virus that will accelerate their
evolution watching from satellites
orbiting the planet above
in no time at all we will have created
planets filled with our own
proto-humans we will be
gods except
it all goes wrong the apes never make it
and the virus doesn't infect them the
virus
infects spiders children of time is one
of the best books i've read in a long
time and it's easily the best sci-fi
book i have perhaps
ever read and i want to tell you why for
starters it has some of the coolest
world building i have
ever seen it takes place over thousands
of years so you're literally watching
the ascendancy of this
sentient spider civilization they use
ant colonies as computers in this book
i mean i know that sounds crazy but the
way that they do it is just so damn cool
tchaikovsky really digs into what would
it be like if spiders were the
dominant species how would they live how
would they think
the spiders have equivalents of the
prisoner's dilemma but they think in
terms of intricate interconnectivity
of a well not just of sight but of
constant vibration and scent
the idea of two prisoners incapable of
communication would not be an acceptable
status quo for them
but a problem to overcome the prisoner's
dilemma is a gordian knot
to be cut through rather than be bound
by
ah it's so good thematically the story
juxtaposes the ascendancy of spider
civilization with the degeneration and
breakdown of human civilization there
are two parallel stories that are
brought crashing together here and it
really asks
what does it mean to be civilized what
does it mean to be human when not only
we forget
part of our humanity but we forget the
knowledge that humanity has collectively
brought together over our evolution
what do we become and what does that
make the spiders
one of the problems with writing stories
that take place over thousands of years
is how do you have consistent character
perspectives but he manages to do that
really well not only with the humans
but with the spiders who go through
generations there are recurring
characters who sort of inherit things
from their parents
which i thought was a really cool world
building mechanic as well also if i
sound sick it's because i am it's making
it immensely hard to record
fundamentally children of time is a
story about empathy it's about
understanding things that are
vastly different from us which of course
spiders are perfect for
because what does the average human fear
or revile
more yet as you read it you come to
visualize these characters which take on
the form of
a thing you might really hate and you
like them you
root for them life is not perfect
individuals will always be flawed but
empathy
the sheer inability to see those around
them as anything other than people too
conquers all in the end tchaikovsky does
this
amazing thing where he literally puts
the reader on the same character arc
as the human characters in the book
itself i love that it's so
meta challenging us to empathize with
these things we would normally
hate and yet even with a story filled
with all of these complicated thematic
ideas
tchaikovsky still manages to write a
story filled with
vibrant characters that we care about a
story that you really get into on a
personal level not just an ideological
one now this isn't me saying that it's a
character-centric story because you
really do fall in love with the worlds
themselves the world of the spiders the
world of the humans which is why the
sense that they're constantly on a
collision course is so
tense and he pulls it off in this
beautiful ending so incredibly well
he he ties all of these thematic and
world building and character threads
together but if you're looking for a
book which is a character study then
maybe children of time isn't that but
that's not a weakness of the book any
more than saying oh there's not enough
action scenes it's just not the type of
book that it is
and i have to point out that the writing
itself is just fantastic
it's mature without being obtuse it's
accessible without being plain it's
insightful without being heavy-handed
when iran kern says humanity is
overrated
there's this deep sense of cynicism that
you go
yeah we kind of are when you read this
book but it's also well
i won't spoil that what criticisms do i
have of children of time
honestly it feels a little bit forced to
give them but
as i said before it's not a book about
character work it still has characters
who are great
and you root for them or you hate them
and they have character arcs and they
change
but it's not a book about character work
it's not
a john green novel it's not american
gods
so if you're looking for that this might
not be for you
but here is why i think it's an amazing
book if you want to get into sci-fi or
if you're already reading sci-fi
it avoids so many of the pitfalls of
modern science fiction
and it avoids the pitfalls of old
science fiction
while keeping the strengths of both it's
a massive scale story while still
being small and it's thematically deep
without being obnoxious and you know
what's even cooler
the sequel children of ruin is also damn
amazing
so you can read that i just drove
through both of these
so absolutely recommend go pick them up
now but that's all for me let me know
down below what you thought of children
of time and
other books that you want me to review
in the meantime stay nerdy
and i'll see you in the future